[موسيقى]
انه اقدم الحيوانات البريه على قيد الحياه
عمره 190 عاما فقد حصتي النظر والشم لكنه
لا يزال متمتعا بحاسه السمع
وقادرا على انجاب المزيد من ذريته
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
التابعه لبريطانيا,54
عند تفكيري في ان جونس ولد في العصر
الجورجي وتحديدا عام
نشعر بالذهول لان العالم شهد التغيرات
كثيره منذ ذلك الوقت بينها الحربان
العالميتان
[موسيقى]
جون ثاني يعيش حياه غايه في الرفاهيه
والدلال يسكن في حديقه منزل حاكم الجزيره
ويسير وفقا نظام غذائي انصار منه
الخضروات والفواكه من خارج الجزيره تاتي
له خصيصا عبر القوارب وتجهز وجباته
اليوميه في مطبخ حاكم الجزيره وصول جنا
فان غير معروفه على وجه الدقه لكن يعتقد
انه نوع من السلاحفليه
من عمره تقريبا
[موسيقى]
ونقدر
الا ان له رفيقه تدعى ايميلي لكنها مقارنه
بعمر الجنافان تبدو طفله فا عمرها 50 عاما
فقط
طوابع بريديه تحمل صورته كما طبعت على
احدى العملات المعدنيه بالجزيره تقديرا له
الجزيره تستعد اليوم
بعد وفاته
[موسيقى]